you got the thumb up okay welcome to the
uh council meeting dated the 28th of
November um and I've already announced
that we have a slight change for two
papers as we come into the into the
agenda I asse why the numbers around the
table we have no
apologies um and nobody zooming nobody
is zooming Margaret welcome to the
meeting it's your chance to have some
time with us absolutely long as you just
keep the microphone quiet close to you
knowing that you've got a quiet voice
you be a to see
me I'm not allowed to say that because
Ria gets offended I'm the only one
allowed to say
that should we go absolutely so welcome
as long as you just keep that microphone
close so so that we can hear
you is that okay that's excellent thank
you for your welcome yes I'm Margaret
cook and I chair the southern community
housing group and thank you for the
opportunity to speak with you all
today our report is on page 10 of your
meeting agenda notes and I'm speaking to
part of
that to State the obvious solving the
issue of how to house the homeless
is complex therefore challenging and I'd
like to thank mayor Clark for the
articles in September in the media
helping to raise awareness our group has
been working on this issue or working
through this issue for about 3 years now
it's been on our
agenda our report in your notes shows
the processes currently happening in the
social housing area of council and
state-owned rentals with a little on of
private rentals
these have gained some traction since
last we reported but still are not
keeping up with the number of
applications for homes despite the
increased building programs of both
Council and K Aura the waiting lists
keep growing and that cohort of homeless
not on waiting lists is a real
challenge the first part of the answer
is in simple terms is to keep building
or rehabilitating more properties the
second part is about the homeless
unregistered cohort who spend their
night sleeping rough in the parks in
shock doorways empty buildings
langland's car park and
elsewhere we acknowledge that for some
it is a lifestyle choice but for others
it's been thrust upon them by
circumstance and we believe we have a
duty of care for their
well-being page three of our report
under future challenges section A
bullets what two and three notes our
current Focus the consideration of
establishment of a City Mission type
facility and the development of
Standalone single transitional
accommodation units complete with
cooking and ablution facilities shared
in
common our group has agreed that we will
explore these two suggestions with a
view to reporting back to our next
quarterly meeting on the 7th of
December and that exploration includes
seeking answers to the questions what
makes a successful night shelter and
what are the pitfalls two members of our
group are seeking information from
existing successful night shelters in
other
cities it includes also seeking data on
the size of the cohort locally anecdotal
information ranges from 20 to maybe 50
individuals one member who has access to
some of them on a weekly basis basis
we'll develop a survey and report back
to our next
meeting it was a felt that approaching
the group called safe in the South for
information would be a useful way to
meet various members in one space until
we found that it was disbanded two years
ago so now those membership groups will
have to be approached individually for
their insights into this issues groups
including the police the fire service
Mari wardens Emergency Management
Southland and community
Patrol we at the group canvased what a
night shelter in inago could offer just
an evening meal a meal and a bed with
shower facilities add in a breakfast
include a laundry we don't know we're
exploring it is acknowledged that these
clients may have complex needs health
issues addictions Financial
wo it was agreed that information about
access to re relevant Services could be
available n
Mamu has agreed in principle that they
are interested in being
involved it was suggested all these
suggestions came at our meetings it was
suggested that the appropriate framework
for running such a shelter would be by
way of a
trust South Community Law Center has
been approached and has agreed to assist
with the drawing up of an appropriate
trust document with advice on the
relevant bodies and processes
required for the transitional housing
concept there are a number of models
nationally and internationally where
well-managed tiny homes or cabins have
met need and have positive
outcomes earlier this year was reported
to our group that more than 60 persons
on the register for housing Wanted
single
accommodation obviously that does not
include the non-registered cohort who
would also require single accommodation
many single persons end up in hostile
situations that they actually find are
less than ideal hence the choice to
sleep
rough given the current rate of
construction it will be many years
before permanent housing developments
meet demand for this
demographic it is felt that once
supported with funding and appropriate
sites found then they can be quickly
established more than one site would
allow for appropriate and safer
groupings of people
our research will also include delving
into the annual plans of territorial
authorities and submitting for
variations of that is deemed necessary
we will also inquire of other existing
models for their successes and
pitfalls and of course there will be a
cost this is where the setting up of a
trust comes into play because such an
entity can apply for funding whereas our
group has no legal status to do
so with with this report we are not at
this time seeking anything from Council
except maybe verbal support and
endorsement that in council's view this
cause has Merit such a decision would be
in line with the council's endorsement
of the original 2017 housing strategy
the monitoring and promotion of which
was passed to our group this is not to
say that further into our resar research
we may not come back to council with
some specific
requests thank thank you for your
attention today and I'm happy to receive
questions and comments so Margaret from
me first I guess um yes we've had this
on a gender as well as you will away um
very complex area um by Tom and LA are
part of your group and are um at our um
enclosement are looking at what works
elsewhere in New Zealand and more
importantly what has not worked well
elsewhere to make sure we cover the
issues it seems to me that there are a
couple of three key issues one is who
purchases the house maybe that's a role
for Council in the future house as in
houses because you probably need a male
and a female one separated um the other
issue is what happens to the management
plans that wrap around those houses so
they tend to be the people be in a trust
but still need funding to actually run
the house provide the food manage the
accommodation and then wider again is
the wraparound services that it's no
good just providing Services they need
mental health they need drug and alcohol
support they need working income and
lots of other stuff as well so um we're
heavily invested in that we're also
looking at um how that might fit within
our uh District plan where we could have
such houses if they're not big houses
and as you refer to the cabins or tiny
houses and to that end um I'm also party
to the tiny homes Association which is a
national body that looks at small houses
that can be mobile I mean they're not
mobile but they've got wheels on them so
they get around some of the
laws understand that yeah but they have
Central blocks as well and that allows
for people to be isolated as opposed to
being in a hostile situation so we're
looking at all those things um and we're
also looking to
expand um our age care units in a
different way to what we've currently
got so that might be um once it uh move
slightly up in the marketplace that
makes room for other people elsewhere so
but this is as you say it's very very
complex area so are you suggesting that
um we could step back and let Council
get on with it or are we complimenting
no not at all you know you're no no nice
try very nice try um no no not at all
look we we need Community buy into this
yes absolutely that's not an easy an
easy thing to do um you know it's no
secret that we're trying to dispose of
some assets that we've got that might um
free up in the housing space our ability
to do a whole range of things including
this night Sher concept so thank you y
so Tom's giving me the wink I mean that
means he wants to say something I think
um thanks we try turn this into a
question but um Margaret but for
probably more for the benefit other
counselors who don't know um Leslie and
I have been looking at the night
shelter um option for inago I didn't
like to name you in my report but no
don't give him any credit and um
Leslie's going to look at one in will
glamorous chance to go to Wellington to
look at one and I'm going to go to denen
so I drew the Short Straw so I I go to
den later this week um we've already
collected a lot of information which um
you know I don't think it's appropriate
or with the time you go now but at some
point we will but just very much in
summary you know Den Nate shelter um has
a budget of 30 $50,000 a year um employe
for people but the majority of the work
is actually done by volunteers so things
like food preparation and so forth is
done by volunteers and and actually the
trust members and other volunteers I
think they've got one group called The
grandmothers or something that does all
the cooking there's actually quite a
substantial number of people who
dedicate a lot of time to keep that
facility running so one of the real
issues for any trust that takes that own
is going to be you know is a sufficient
um commitment because once you're into
it you're into it the other comment I
would make is the the needan inventory
for um people who are rough sleepers is
about 20 and they have done an inventry
so it may be a little bit surprising if
we've got more than that you'd think on
a per Cabo basis we would have less um
so the numbers are true rough sleepers
over might be a smaller number they are
actually have a relatively small
facility that only sleeps about six
people yeah and yet um Leslie and I were
told that they actually very rarely run
out of beds so you and the the men and
women share the same building but with
locked doors so we don't necessarily
have to be you know a hugely complicated
or a hugely expensive Affair but it is
more about the number of people who are
prepared to commit time not so much
money but more prepared to commit time
to do things like food preparation and
you know all these sorts of things that
you know they at least in Den don't
actually employ people who do lesli you
aren add
anything probably a couple of the
Practical things to add is that one of
those employees is a social worker
support person for the residents that
they do have um rules as you would
expect in any such facility about how
often a person can access the facility
there are very clear rules was about um
drug and
alcohol um and the need and
interestingly is in the perhaps
fortunate situation where the property
does have some Standalone properties um
on the site which can be used for longer
term okay uh facility so it is an a
interesting setup from that to point of
view the trust runs both um but the
ongoing cost says Tom said of that
annual budget means that there is
constant trustee
fundraising um constant applications for
funds Etc it is not an easy matter um to
run and the other practical thing is
that there is the need for 24 air
cover so we might be in a position to
encourage the trust to help fund it
potentially
which sorry through you again the the
needen facility gets no fund either from
local or from national government um
national government allow they put in
significant amounts of money for example
at the Wellington night shelter I think
they put in about half a million dollars
a year to that um we of the view that um
denen and I suspect they would say the
same about Inver cargot is a wealthy
enough area they can afford to do
themselves so they put no money into the
neither do theen city council all of the
money is raised actually by charitable
donations so it's hard work actually for
the for the trustees um but the other
comment is worth making is it's not all
um well none of it actually is easy but
if you look at the Wellington example
the Wellington night shelter folded two
or three years ago for reasons that you
know when I go to Margaret's meeting um
next week I think it is I I'll go in a
lot more detail but but actually
Leslie's going up be but it failed it
was an next shter that failed so it's
quite possible actually even although
they get half a million dollars a year
from central government and quarter a
million from Wellington city council it
failed so it's it's not only about money
it's about actually I think it's
actually mainly about the quality the
trustees and the quality the the
volunteers that's actually what makes a
difference sure thank Youk you yeah
thanks chair L M's just a comment thank
you very much for the work you're doing
it's a really important piece of our
community we need to take care of and I
fully would support the council being a
partner with a trust in some way shape
or form to to help support this
understand the challenges they are
significant but we shouldn't step back
from that we should lean into those
challenges for these people because they
are vulnerable so thank you
work Trish um Margaret I'm sure you're
aware but there's a number of rotary
clubs who are service clubs yes Caro and
you know if you put it before the group
of presidents they may may well take it
on as you know a support area in terms
of helping or also
fundraising thank you that is sort of
step two yes yeah but it's just I
thought it's was a good opportunity yes
thank you yes I would envisage churches
also rostering for cooking
yeah uh
you Margaret
um my problem with the the night shelter
concept is that it doesn't resolve the
bigger problem which is these people
need somewhere all the time and the idea
of you've got a bed one night but you
don't the next night is very disturbing
to me and I understand that that's how
most of the night shelters operate
everywhere in the world I do understand
that
but I think sometimes it seems like it's
an easier fix to
provide bed for a night I think the
bigger issue for me is to actually find
how we get the kind of housing that give
people the Privacy they need the
certainty they need the actual money
that they need so what do you think we
should be doing right you know are we
going for the loow hanging fruit by
looking at night shelter as opposed to
um certainty permanent or appropriate
long-term placing I wouldn't certainly
wouldn't describe it as loow hanging
fruit it's a really difficult place to
go I agree one night is not sufficient
and my
reading and I shouldn't preempt what the
discussion is going to be next week but
my understanding is that they can come
people can come back night after night
they just have to disappear during the
day yes um and it's not the solution
it's it's a Band-Aid I agree with that
the ideal thing would be to find housing
for all of them we we haven't got it we
have can't house our
existing homeless people families and
families I would suggest would get a
precedent over single
people um so that cohort will always
struggle yes the ideal thing would be to
be very successful and further down the
track have all the buildings built and
all the families housed and and we would
run out of business and that would be a
good thing praise we we would re
repurpose the
building so so maret before I go to some
others um I've worked in Social Services
as you know um this is a very complex
area the key is not the housing or the
meals at night time the key is the
wraparound
Services I have spoken with Tracy yeah
really important I mean it you can try
as much as you like with someone who's
got major mental health issues yes while
we see them sitting rough sleeping rough
they're not worried about that they've
got much much bigger issues going on in
their lives AB same for the drug and
alcohols also so Tracy will be attending
our next meeting yep to see how what
we're doing y Maria and thank you thanks
Margaret for your um in depth um report
to us um there was a program
uh 2016 17 15 16 17 and I think by
memory was in Hamilton West at um
different groups looked at how they
could help with the rough sleeping and
people that needed night accommodation
um and that that I think that was
successful for over a 3year time frame
um it's not currently there at the
moment and coming up to what the M said
it is the W around services like we know
what we can do for them and provide for
them at night time but what can we give
them in the daytime which is why it's
good to see that Tracy um will come on
board um a lot of that may may may sorry
may come on board and see where um
refound Services can be provided we know
that for some people that it's not a
choice it's an Absol Last Resort um do
we know I know I know that in the report
we don't have exact figures but when we
talk about families do we know how many
families currently yes the numbers are
in the report families come under a
different different workspace yeah so K
Aura is responsible for that and and
they sit at our table as well
okay okay
so this is just one um when you get time
to read a report you'll find the blue
headings of all the parts of work that
we we've cover yeah so I saw the
different agencies that that directive
with yeah
um families that aren under the k k or
space there are R sleeping at in our
city there are there are some do we know
those numbers but is what I mean no
I'll come back to you Leslie um P um I
also I also want to acknowledge the work
that you are doing and love to see you
again and and yeah nothing's really
changed I feel feels like this has been
a a roller coaster absolutely for you um
I just also want to CU your synergies
with
um Holly house you know where we used to
send Young to you know and educate
things like that but they was you know
there sort of synergies having those
wraparound services like me um carus
just sort of talked about but one of the
things I want to say talk about is
really the K order and how in the work
that they're doing because they're
actually assisting um a in regards to
the K so I'm wondering how all these
could be linked up in somewh for them
they all they are all linked up um K
young sits at our table okay from K Ora
um the Methodist Mission sits at our
table they have a house for young moms
and they've got seven young moms and
babes there now that's an i Street um
and of course we've got the school my
place which caters
for young moms there as well there are
things all over the city that are great
and are working well there's just this
little patch that nobody's done anything
about absolutely and and you know two
Winters ago I wanted to have something
done you know they're not going through
another winter in
inago here I am two Winters later and
it's still not happening but that's you
know it's the way things roll and the
disruptor of Co didn't help love to
support you in your way of for thank
you so before I go to Les again M um
just to acknowledge there are a lot of
players on this field yes there are um I
often ask people who are in the field
how many are there how many agencies are
there around both government and
non-government that help at risk
families best I tend to get is about 20
is actually 85 yeah in the city so there
are a significant amount of resources
around but they're not well connected
between each other and the key is the
wraparound organizer on the on a daily
basis that knows where to go knows who
the key people are to get to to get them
Services they need so and that's what
lesle was alluding to before that that's
the most critical position I think lesle
thanks Mr Mayor I was just going to add
because people have talked about
it the all the research Tom and I have
done so far on the various
setups um emphasize the absolute
necessity of all the trusts having
social worker staff y as part of the
trust employee framework for the very
purposes of wraparound services
assistance with transitioning people
into a more stable housing environment
than when they come into the emergency
facility
um assisting people to move on with
their lives as Margaret's
indicated sometimes that is not
successful sometimes it is very
successful and we've heard some stories
haven't we Tom where it has been
successful and has resulted in a stable
housing situation for a who came into a
night
shelter with nothing so that that is one
of the one of the things we certainly
picked up from the research so far that
good without without the wraparound
services and the actual qualified people
to do that um you are never going to
have anything that will succeed in this
field it may provide a few nights but it
won't provide a future that's right and
and just to add to that often the
coordinator can get doors open with the
other services where the actual
individual can't because they've got
history with them that's right yes uh
Barry yeah well done Margaret for your
work very well done thank you um I was
just wondering about the Salvation Army
do they not they're sitting at our table
oh yeah okay well I'm just just in
relation to their old building um they
stopped doing that sort of service I'm
the wrong person to ask I don't actually
know why yeah I I can help with that um
Salvation Army nationally have made a
decision that they're not going to be in
this field they've elected not to be in
so we've got to find other players that
want to help manage the under the night
shelters yes they're no longer Supply
they've stopped doing it up yeah
Nationwide keep up your good work you're
doing right thank you keep helping
me Ria the lucky last question oh yes I
was um I see that you've also got the
southern breathing breathing space trust
um on your table too so how can their
service um as a trust help with
this I'm not
sure should I ask LLY
sorry put you on the spot
sorry as as is known from my Council
conflict um portfolio I am the cheer of
the breathing space trust in
yes we have two emergency housing units
which will be available from early next
year um we have worked very closely with
Margaret's community housing group we
have been representative on that group
from the very beginning y
um we are very grateful to Rotary which
has helped support the two units but the
two units is not sufficient we will have
the wraparound services we will have the
assistance but the two units is a small
part of the picture it was never the
answer to the entire
issue can I oh yeah yeah Margaret you
can responding to two other thoughts
that came sorry for the slowness of the
clicking um there was a thousand days
trust yes it folded lost its funding
really important work that they were
doing and the Hamilton one I read about
they were taking over empty shops I
think and they were yeah they
were and I think I think that what
Leslie raised was an important issue
that if you have mandatory times that
you can only stay for five consecutive
days your wraparound Services probably
won't work because you don't wrap
services around that quickly yes so
that's going to be the ongoing challenge
lots of challenges we're not denying
that lot challenges Tom uh I was just
going to say and it it goes to the
discussion that we've been having the
the um I mean I think the conventional
model of a night shell is a place that
gives resp care yeah so fundamentally
somebody would usually an individual
would would come in spend up to five
nights would get an opportunity to get
shes and get cleaned and washed and
clothes and then would go on the road
again and that that was the the the the
thing that's made it much more complex
now is that those individuals seem to
become fewer and fewer and more and more
those shelters have been asked to deal
with people with extremely complex
problems that require clearly longer
Term Care on that um you know just
having them there for a few days and um
sending them away there a very limited
help yes and and the the the two areas
are becoming actually a little bit
confused and it's making it far more
complicated than it used to be
individuals list theide individual who
um runs in sherland theen is the
individual who used to run the Salvation
Army shelter and in Pago okay um and
took all of those skills with them so
there is very you know there is real
skills that you need to find in the
person that's doing that kind of work so
it's a kind of sector if I call it a
sector and transition away from rest
care and more towards you know longer
term yes care which I think when goes to
Wellington I think that's what they've
tended to do from what we've read but
that's a lot you know you need a lot
more places surean yeah yeah a lot more
services as well it's not a five minute
job no no I mean I can tell you from
certainly from my experience Tom and
Margaret that when you wrap services
around people it can be every day for 3
to 5
years it's very very complex area with
my Habitat for Humanity hat on and as a
20 year career in special education I
understand totally what that
about okay any other questions no you're
released thank you very much for your
inut not convicted no not yet and no
that we we're working
on does does raise the issue around
social housing yeah well it also raise
the issue about how the government many
years ago
took okay councilors we just need to
accept a major light late item now which
Michael to my left has throwing the
curveball at us which is the uh local
government submission paper going
forward and how we want to vote on that
so you just like to some like to move
yes
Grant yeah thank you Darren all those in
favor I carried do
that I'm going through the agenda all
right so this is where we will sit nice
and Silent now while Les and Darren do
all the
minutes so the first one on the agenda
is the uh um connected M joint committee
meeting held on the 9th of
October Council broad might like to do
that sorry to wake you up there a second
I'll second that yeah Alex thank you any
questions about that yeah yes so um just
page 16 board box see there's a
discussion about reporting back that
what what are the objectives of that
program or role and I note in another
paper that we're funding it so I are the
objectives of that program really really
clear in terms of the outcomes that will
be
achieved no you go first well I've kind
of come into this with fresh eyes I
didn't really understand the the journey
to this point yeah um and I guess I've
spoken to that in the in the in the
meetings the the why what's the value
what's the relevance and my concern was
that um we're just creating another
funding and creating another Forum which
wouldn't have a g through but I think it
needed so I think there was a lot more
clarity brought to that last meeting
since this P um around the need to
really speak in the sector and those um
agencies that are going to be
involved and find it's me to be lead by
the community but really find the value
find the relevance what they need and
then come back and produce essentially
the evidence to that need is that yeah I
I can jump on onto it so apparently this
is a peace work that's been undertaken
you know PRI coming on board and then
appointing really um project managing
this piece of work um it's really
focused around the community and social
sector so there's so many services out
there but but they're just not connected
so it's providing uh an electronic type
platform to actually where people can
start linking and connecting all the
services rather than working in silos um
and there been some other things there's
been a number of Hy held prior as well
which a lot of the um po Focus has
dropped out off so we're just slightly
Roofing that up now
yeah describe it like the business chain
before these agencies so to to go into
your research and then come back what is
their need so whether that be governance
training within these organizations
funding opportunities and and and
resources for that that then link into
so it's really empowering those
agencies um around some key yeah so so
how will you measure success of the
program
well we probably yet to through
what so we would see them back once
they're
agreed see
the agreed yeah yeah
cool well the task right now from vix is
frame up what it looks like what it is
where the value is where the relevance
relevance these agencies is and then
going from there but I still think that
has been what she's been tasked that is
what she's been tasked with ready to
come back and show evidence of the need
relevance and then from there we will be
establishing some objectives with her so
Steve for your benefit um CU I was
involved in the original part of this
discussion I don't think the brief was
to connect with agencies and look at
what they need it was really the
connection which was the key that the
platform would allow you to go on and
have a look so to that end I gave
somebody and I can't remember who the
remiss of me not to remember U the list
of that I hold of 85 agencies so I'll
give that to you as well because that
should surely be most of my Social
Service Agency should should surely be
the starting point for the database
because it it lists the name key
contacts
emails te uh cell phone numbers and all
that sort of stuff but part part of that
is also introduce yourself um so yeah I
don't think the idea was to develop the
agencies it was more to develop the
connection between the agencies well
it's a network between those sure
absolutely and with a database that you
can
access and the thing is it's not for us
to sort of like take over anyway it's
how can we actually
support agencies to
connect and how can communities actually
have a platform where they can go to
Y to find the services that they
need I guess what I was signaling and it
might be my uptake at the initial
discussion was not the former so the
idea was to identify where these
agencies are and there are lots on there
hundreds literally hundreds um and
connect them up onto a common database
that connects us up uh I'm not sure her
brief because her brief is a very short
brief um TimeWise um is to actually
start getting into what do the agencies
need by way of support or development
but I might have that wrong no you're
right can I sure Alex thank you I just
wanted to really add because it was just
me men at the start there by Council Dum
that um looks like we're funding it just
wanted to be really clear we are not
actually funding it not coming out I can
clarify that we've got central
government funding funding we do have we
we manage the contract city council do
so for us um you know like it's
Community benefer for for no experence
yeah from from from us yeah central
government P yeah on this one yep any
other
question everyone yes I want to clarify
because I was actually on the original
program so it came out of the just
transitions work it's out of the social
need and the feeling of social isolation
that was very much evident at the time
and it's not just social service
agencies it's it could anybody can put
their organization on that Network cuz
if you are sitting lonely somewhere and
you think who
does is there a crochet group I can join
the crochet group how you contact
because what we discovered during the
conversations was that the most obvious
things were not actually necessarily the
biggest needs we have a big Refugee
population that finds it very hard to
get networks and things like that so if
you're sitting somewhere where there's
not a lot of other people speak to your
language or what how do you get in touch
with someone that can help you and you
can go into the website and find so it's
bigger than the social agencies it's the
whole social framework and how we can
better connect People to
People
R that's okay it's would be nice okay
excellent Trish um the Community Trust
did quite a a big piece of research in
this area while I was working there I
don't know whether Rebecca knows that or
whether she's been in touch with the
Community Trust but they have a large
database they collected um so it would
be worth and similar what nby was saying
it's got addresses emails the whole
works I think Jackie's part of her
Jackie's part of the group as oh she
what's before her time as well the the
citizens advice Bureau also has a very
large database and that is connected and
as part of so it's a it's to develop
that even with a couple of databases
around there is still still a lot of
silos out there that are not connected
and this is to assist the connections to
be stronger and to deliver more
effectively yep thank you all right
further questions all those in
favor
carried minut of the bluff community
board on Monday the 16th of October
Grant Barry and Barry I wasn't at the
meeting he went at the me that's that's
reckless Barry's got it somebody like
the second second thank you any
discussions around the minutes just just
one sorry well no if you weren't there
you can't put your hand up now come on
no just and it's probably to Jonathan
that report around the unsafe buildings
we we' we've progressed
that through you uh chair sorry can you
repeat the question um I think um Timmy
asked his cheer around a request a
report about unsafe buildings and Bluff
and what actions will be taken that was
a verbal report that I gave what that
was what it was there's nothing further
coming through no okay all right thank
you okay any further questions no all
those in favor I carried minutes of the
extraordinary Great South joint
shareholders committee on the 20th of
October I think I was there so I'll move
those seconded car oh sorry thank you
any discussions around
those yes Ry um where do we go to find
the agendas for those
and are they live
streamed
which no no or uh I'm not sure about the
first question second question is no not
live streamed and so that's one of the
issues I will have on the agenda this
Friday for the meral Forum because given
the
om's uh advice recently um we don't live
stream the miral forum either so that
opens up a a whole lot of um we should
be live streaming yeah I mean absolutely
You' still I see in the um
minutes there are there's a public
exclude session obviously but why isn't
this transparency
consistent that we're trying to do with
workshops that's exactly what I'll be
asking on Friday you can be sure of that
um because that's that's a double
standard to my way of thinking and what
about the
agendas well I I normally get it's not
on their website Megan normally sends me
the agenda
shouldn't it be on the website shouldn't
you publish an agenda Michael will
answer this thank you yeah through
yourself um the the agendas are provided
to the members prior to the meeting the
week before so historically we haven't
been uh haven't minuted these on a
regular basis through to council we've
rectified that um issue and now making
sure that these minutes come back to
Council on a regular basis straight
after the meeting um but also so
addressing the attendance question that
is part of the that's in the minutes
from that perspective they actual agenda
uh that goes to the members that are
attending the meeting we we we publish
out like this this is in the public
records the agenda we've got today why
wouldn't great South's agenda be in the
public records yep so you can leave that
with me I will definitely take I mean I
won't go over how much we fund them but
yeah yeah no no
um I'll come back to on that on Ry
because um that's an issue of not only
the live stream but also the agenda
thank you Mr Mayor you're
welcome any further questions all those
in
favor
carried next one is is bullet point 8
which is the hearing of the city block
west held on the 24th of October move
the move seconded y standed two that we
nor have any discussion about
those all those in
favor minutes of the council meeting on
the 31st of October moves no
sorry not one of the ones you put your
hand up for thank you Darren thank you
Lesley any discussion around those all
those in favor say
I okay extraordinary meeting of council
on the 7th of November second mov thank
you moved any any discussion around
those
minutes no there being none all those in
favor infrastructure committee meeting
on the 7th of November yeah I move those
yeah thank you R seconded here's your
chance pish all right yeah thank
you any
discussions okay all those in favor I
Carri minutes of the committee wellbeing
committee um held on the 14th of
November so I'll move those including
the recommendation to council yep so
I'll thank you lizy so could you just
give us a a little we update on that
because there was some contention around
that wasn't there some well some public
feedback around whether we should have a
sinking liad or a cap and how that cap
might work just for those who weren't
present we've stuck with the cap
okay which means the number stays the
same but they can trans
ER the uh yes it is possible to transfer
into the
city if they're in a Suburban location
correct okay thank you any questions
around
that no none that was easy uh all those
in favor I
carried the minutes of the extraordinary
finance and project committee right
thank you seconded yeah thank you all
those in favor a few question question
oh sorry you have a question Darren
Darren has a
question all those in favor was Carri
minut of the bluff community board held
on the 20th of November with a
recommendation Barry were you there this
time Grant yes I was yes excellent
seconded
there and so we have we have a
recommendation do you want to talk to
that Grant or
bearing what is
reading with
lips yeah yeah they
disgusting outlined very well by Michael
moris yep yes they done able to do and
uh yep okay any discussion around there
no okay all those in
favor carried right now the one that we
bringing from Tisbury so before we do
that Wayne if you'd like to come forward
we're bringing this into an open session
but I will give you the the chance to
speak to if you wish about why we should
keep this in PE given that you've seen
what I've written to you and Marcus
about previously and Council will been
provy to that email as
well thank you mayor Clark um so the
reason for the request to uh place this
particular report into Tisbury has been
expressed is TE hunger um the reason
behind it is that the E committee have
uh on behalf of the for raka gifted a
name for the new Tisbury uh facility to
council normally the first time that
name is used is during the tapoo lifting
ceremony and it would be regrettable if
we were to tell the public that name
before E we actually have the opport
opportunity to lift the tapoo on that
particular site hence the reason for the
request for this particular paper to be
um dealt with as a public excluded item
um that that is the reason it is a um a
courtesy but also Tia uh as far as the
the for raka um are concerned and this
is what has been expressed uh through
the E commit to me and so I've just
simply conveyed that
through the writing of this paper to
council sure so as an offset of that and
why I moved it to be an open just so you
understand is that um we made some
decisions early on about um about
bilingual names and even though the
current government may change that
landscape for us we're still committed
to that um and that we also in the paper
which got left on the table at the time
of that decision making um wanted to
make sure that we could work through
these namings in a um quiet approach I
guess and not not be faced with a
meeting where one of the parties
objected because that then gets to a
confrontational stage so hence we would
very much like to um have it in public
and so we can explore some issues around
both the English and the um e name or
the tyo name H we come into public um so
um I'll start the ball rolling on the
English one um oh sorry um it's not in
public it's not in public yet okay um
may I speak to what you have asked yep
um Mr Meritt
so I think it's fair to say that I'm
probably um one of the few people that's
been involved in several naming of
building ceremonies um both at dawn and
other times um from an e perspective
it's really is traditional that the name
name is covered it's not publicly
visible um until such time as those that
who are doing the cut here ask what is
the name of the building what is the
building for there's there's some
there's some processes
um I
think as we go on our journey with these
things this is a question that is going
to come before us more
to have names of significance means that
you're you're accepting that there are
some protocols and there are some
processes the thing that makes this
particular one par very important is
what the purpose is for us doing it next
Wednesday in order for everything to be
moved out of the museum there are some
very special items that need to be moved
in order for them to be moved the
building needs to be named and have the
mody stone and everything else go with
it so there's an order to it it would be
I
believe very respectful of this Council
to acknowledge that not everything is
done the same way by everybody but this
particular thing involves human remains
and some very traditional practices so
that is the reason why it's some public
excluded I would beg the
council's um consideration favorably
to honoring the
request without delaying the public
knowing the name later than
11:00 next Wednesday is that
unreasonable and so I leave it at
there so so before we get any further
and I'll allow other people to
contribute um this is where it gets
uneasy for me because we named the M new
Museum well in advance of any um
unveiling or any uh naming of the museum
because it's important that the
community know what we're naming it and
why we know it the way we are and that
wasn't the process when we did
tanu
so worship it it was because tanoa is a
name that was given to the site that is
y um currently where
haaka um
resides revealed at that point for
Museum project so there is a difference
I'll allow py to have some input here um
and then others can speak and we'll do a
vote on whether it stays in public or
goes to the public
SC okay so um sorry I'm very much in the
same thinking as Evelyn but this is T
that we're following and because this
place is holding our tonger and and
everything that's really significant to
us and so following you know following a
process of tap is really
important so I also would be the council
to consider
that okay
Tom I I mean sorry I don't know if
whether it
actually
um whether it's under t or or where it
comes from as I understand it reading it
um under Section 7 it's the reason for
withholding is to protect information
provided under an obligation of
confidence and if that was the
understanding that the name was given
under then then we are satisfying the
act by holding it in um in public
excluded so I don't makes any difference
that it's you know a Tero name it's just
anything provided under obligation of
confidence
yeah ringy thanks chair look I don't
think Wayne could have explained it more
simply or clearly than he did and to me
what he said is is right but I also like
to highlight an inconsistency in a in a
in an item that's coming up in bilingual
naming that in the report there is no
and naming the airport there is no
inclusion of being a Civic building
there is no inclusion of the bilingual
approach now you know this is something
that council did I'll raise it later but
I just like to highlight it now yep
that's fine I understand where you come
from that R um I also want to um raise
and support of Evelyn and P's um ver
oral um reasons to us I think that
having our Tonga and also some human
remains and there is enough for me to
that's tapoo so yeah make make it simple
I've previously suggested it comes into
open and I'll move that and see where
that goes anybody sorry leie did you
want to speak to that yes I I before you
moved I I did want to speak to the
issue and my perspective is it's a
gifted name it was gifted under an
obligation of trust and confidence
Tanger would be ex
respected I think this Council
understands what T are being respected
means it does involve T and it does
involve the conveying of human remains
to a new home it is now the 28th of
November y the name will be publicly
revealed on the 7th of December in a
week's
time we are talking about a week of
respecting
teanger y I just do not think that we
have any argument for breaking the
confidence that we have given
and and bringing into public something
that we know is under that trust and
confidence
obligation that's all I wanted to say
okay anybody else want to speak to that
bar yeah um I made it very excuse me I
made it pretty plain that I was not all
in favor of the museum having its T name
and I'm going to be exactly the same
with this
one hasn't going out to public that's
for another discussion um so um do I
have a second for the motion to bring
this into
open you do so oh sorry I put the motion
that this issue be discussed in public
not in public excluded oh okay so you
didn't have your hand up for that did
you no I think do the RSE okay no second
that means it stays in in public
excluded okay come back to you thank
you the one issue I would make um Leslie
is you're quite right um the naming
needs to be done by the 7th but that
assumes that what's on the paper will be
accepted and that's the other
issue okayy moving on in the
agenda
yeah oh city city
block which is number 15
um findings of the city block a
supplementary
report Patricia is coming up and when he
follows Russell is going to give us his
words of wisdom on the
pillars the floor is yours afternoon
councilors so this paper brings to you
just the I refinancing
options as a result um these were left
on the table when we bought the fall of
the um s Street West consultation
deliberations they were left on the
table so that the finan and projects
committee could receive additional
information from the IC directors which
they have done so and as a result uh
proposing two options whether it's a $10
million purchase of shares or a $20
million purchase or up to $20 million of
purchase of shares BYL
both so if some yes Darren so I would be
prepared to move the recommendations
with option two second y got that any
discussions on
that um page 105 boardbook P or five or
7 year report just the reference here to
the First morgage Security would remain
at 45.5
million is so is there
priority is there priority in the
mortgages it there's a priority in the
mortgage there's a number of mortgages
um between um who Council and hwr
finance we had 45.5 million First
Mortgage so we would keep that even
though hwrf would not be um a party to
that so so why would we not look to
raise raise at that would require the
second and third
mortgages to the second mortgage is to
allow us to have a higher priority and
that was a sticking point at the time we
put that financing and they would only
allow um
45 I think it's 45.5 they would only
allow then they took the next so that's
Community Trust
anding yeah okay no that's fine thank
you okay any further
questions a lot of debate about this all
right I'll put the motion with option
two all those in favor I I
carried
Russell your
enlightment so those who Wen party the
previous previous meeting um some issues
were raised in a paper about
um uh the stability I guess or the NBS
rating of the pillars and potentially it
could be under 32 which has then create
some issues for us going forward um and
Bob Simpson has kindly given us some f
information which I've shared with you
today and Russell has an update for us
as well Mr may this is just a counselers
this is just an update um related to
city block that was raised as part of
that but it's not on the agenda as a
topic so so we can't get to talk and ask
questions yeah floor is yours thanks Mr
me um what I what I have um I've been
back to the engineers to actually
establish what level of plans they had
because I I guess some of the feedback
we're getting was that the foundations
had had needed to be to be confirmed and
we have identified some further
construction drawings which we believe
are um those that were built so that has
um assisted the engineers to look at the
foundations and to generally come to a
conclusion that the foundations
themselves would appear
satisfactory however with the rest of
the construction drawings that we were
able to Prov IDE has identified some
other issues with the um connection of
the columns to the foundations and we
need to do some further com um and I
guess more complete um assessment of
those columns to identify it so I guess
I've got one step forward in terms of
the foundations but we have some other
connections that we have to um continue
to do some work on to identify whether
the strengthening may or may not be
required for the columns um so at the
moment the engineers are recommending
that we would still consider them to be
less than 34% however we still need to
work through the a bit more detail about
how the columns are connected to the
concrete foundations so two quick
questions for me um when will you know
whether those connections are okay and
two when you do decide to give us some
advice on that can you give us some
advice on how complicated it would be to
reinforce those connections that's
correct I think we need to do the two
things we need to make sure we
understand the engineering and the
second part of that is how difficult
will it be to do and what sort of that
what does that cost bring should that be
necessary that are the two elements that
you need to have a direction going
forward okay thank you for that any
further questions of can I just ask we
get a rough time frame for that
information wrestle I would imagine
that's not probable before Christmas but
I would imagine it's by the end of
January we'll try to Target that um in
terms of the overall that doesn't
necessarily impact us with the work in
that area It's actually an issue just to
actually resolve and carry on with that
was Christmas this year wasn't
it correct no Tom can I just clarify
Russell whether the new issue that we
found is because we lack information
about the nature of the um joint if I
can call it that or do we have that
information and they still
concerned
the new information was on the
additional plans that we supplied and
that's really about the connection so
the original the original assessment was
a reasonbly high level and I guess guess
a much more Global type of overturning
type issue whereas now they've looked at
it and have identified specifics about
the um types of connections that have
been applied between the three layers of
the um columns and how they connected
and the forces that will bring into the
concrete so it's sort of down a complete
technical level lower at the moment so
but again sorry just to chase that down
a little bit further is it because of a
a lack of information that we have a
lack of the drawings because we don't
want to see a member of the public
sending the drawings overnight again
right do we like the drawings or do we
have the drawings but just don't feel
comfortable about the we have the design
drawings which we believe were
constructed yes thank you any other
questions no thank you
Russell
okay so I'll just moove that a verbal
update has been
given second y thank you you're too slow
Darren thank you Leslie all those in
favor I
carried and now paper 16 on on our
agenda which is the I CHL resolution to
be approved by Council Andrew
welcome thank you mayor just a couple of
quick resolutions the paper pretty much
speaks for itself but it's just worth
reflecting on the fact that the normal
purpose of a uh an annual general
meeting is an opportunity for the
shareholders to to communicate with the
the company directly I suppose and I
suppose what this paper reflects is that
that conversation is more ongoing so
that uh the board at least don't believe
that there is any additional benefit to
having an annual general meeting as
opposed to that regular update process
but obviously it's up to the councilor
shareholders as whether not they agree
to that approach or not the other one is
really just a tidy up a continued tidy
up of the group structure just to avoid
an entity that really isn't undertaking
any transactions and so just incurs
effectively costs predominantly being
ordered costs and so if we can remove
those costs from the system and that's
an improvement
overall sure you M Clark this ha back to
a time when we only had one opportunity
a year to get in front of ask questions
I'm happy to move the three
recommendation Alex thank you Tom do you
have any view on that sorry put no you
don't okay any other
questions excellent all those in favor
carried you get away easy Andrew not yet
oh not
yet all right next paper being the
recognition of s Tim shedal and I just
want to uh lead into a little bit of
this so people have an understanding
where we've come to um this paper from
my perspective is very much about
acknowledging sir Tim's service to the
city um there has been some significant
debate about um whether he is the
longest serving mayor in New Zealand's
history that is not the case by my
assessment he's
fourth um and so um where some of the
confusion has kicked in is that at the
time of being knighted um there was uh
some commentary that said he was the
longest currently serving me I think
that's confused the the picture so this
is very much about acknowledging his
service to the city having said that
we've had a little bit of debate about
what this should take uh in the past as
you're well aware um we got some
original um acceptance by the family
that this was an appropriate gesture we
got a little bit of backwards movement
in that which is now been clarified um
Michael to my right has um got written
confirmation that's an appropriate
gesture and Tim support group from Tanga
have also confirmed in writing to me
that they are happy with the terminal as
opposed to the full airport so the floor
is yours Andrew I think that pretty much
summarizes position there there is some
good history and I think it to pick up
those points there is some association
with the airport that I think makes the
airport an appropriate place for this to
occur and I think recognizing those it's
a sensible choice there's still some
obviously issues to work through in
terms of the final structure but this
keeps everyone on a a path forward I
suppose yep it would it would be my
expectations that Michael and yourself
Michael to my right and yourself
determine what the final look of that is
we've made some suggestions around
naming and around the use of that
picture that currently sits in the Civic
Theater and some um dialogue I guess on
um that'll allow people to understand
who he is and why we've got that
recognition up there um I think it gets
a bit comp more complicated when
councils start getting into the waterers
it actually look like um given the
nature of the relationship they're
involved so if you're happy to do that
on behalf of the company and Michael
does it from his end as well I think
that would be great Evelyn um so I'm
speaking on behalf of one of the other
shareholders y w Rea is in favor of this
um and to um the question raised earlier
by Council pottinger we did we do not
consider it appropriate to give a
transliteration of a person's proper
name and title so therefore s sheol
terminal is fine by us however my cheer
did wish to point out that we have been
in conversation with inag port for quite
some time about a recognition of toell
Marty within the building so he does not
want you to forget that in your haste to
honor s so we are absolutely delighted
to support and do not wish to have a
transliterated second name or anything
like that but um we will continue our
discussions with the airport about
appropriate to Mar to welcome people to
inag as well so so in response to that
which I can respond to it um I've had
Michael and I and Tom have had some
discussions with the board um and I've
had some with Jordan as who's a chief
executive there and they are both
looking to a future where the in Caro
eBay may very well have Yi included in
the
name and was just separated from this
decision for for reason quite
separ um look just to keep everyone
correct um the shareholders actually own
the company that operates the airport
they do not own the terminal whing yep
okay that's a correction there y so the
terminal building comes under hulco
which we own ourselves okay we are the
only owners of hulco um look I'm just
the reason I raised it is that we're
cons I just want to be consistent uh
with our decision on the 27th of June
where we uh moved the mayor seconded
councilor Campbell that Council adopt a
bilingual approach to any naming or
renaming of a Civic
building and that the naming be
expressed in a dual manner
now you know I'm really just want some
consistency and unless we want to create
a rule book uh for our bilingual naming
policy yep um so uh let me give my Pen's
worth on that um I would not expect sir
Tim's name to be translated I'm just
saying another I'm not asking any more
than a marry name would be translated
into English that would be seen as an
insult I'm not asking for a translation
of him I'm just saying that the name
would appear as an appropriate name for
an airport a bilingual name that's all
well do you oppose to him having his
name on the building is that you're
saying no no no I'm just saying that you
would have the Tim shed Bol just like we
have uh Tim nak for this building or
whatever you would have an appropriate
name um that was suitable for naming an
air an airport terminal so I can confirm
that the company independent of us
approaching them about Cam's name have
already got down that path where they're
looking to a Tero name for the airport
hold up but this is our policy sorry
talking about this is our policy I'm
talking about oh sure but our our policy
surely apply to um to companies that we
own as well you'd expect the same set of
conditions to run across it would be a
bit fful if they didn't but why why
aren't we seeing it today there's no
mention of it in the paper well they
haven't got that failure they they've
got a process to work through we Tom and
I and M day went to see the board about
the um about the possibility of of
having Tim's name on as a terminal there
was some unease I might add with the
directors they came to the position they
didn't want the political debate of
doing that they wanted us to give them a
directive which we've now committed to
doing TR sorry I think it's clearly
there are two issues here as as the
mayor has said we're talking about the
naming of the terminal with Tim shed and
um Evelyn has explained you know the
rang's position what the head have
already done if hulco they've already
said they're going to go down that track
of renaming um things today in today it
it's they're two SE they're two
different
things in my
opinion Alex um thank you wishop um I
think it's just it's clearly an
extenuating circumstance it's not likely
we going to encounter another Tim shed
bolt situation anytime soon um and so I
think well I might not get a name on the
building oh you may not get a name on
the building sorry um M
CLK
so I think it's clear that um we've got
a really obvious uh recognition there
for S Tim shed vaol y maybe when we
formed our policy we didn't actually
consider that we might name things after
to humans y um and I think we should
just get on with it to be honest at at
the time I put the paper up Alex for
your benefit um I did have two criteria
in it and be mindful the paper got left
on the table um one was that we would
not um use Tero names on historical
buildings like the Scottish Hall that
would be inappropriate yeah any more
than we'd put an English title on the
morai um and the other example I used
was that we would not change the library
name given it had Eve Paul's name on it
as well so um
Tom well we already heard from Evelyn
that the um name preferred by maneno is
s Tim shadal if you want to Jo name it
we could have stim shadb and either some
stim shadb below or above it we can
debate whether stim shadb should be
below or above the names of Tim
shadb
um one would be tartan yeah yeah this is
going this is going to be one of the
silliest debates we've ever had
honly
Le thank you M Clark look it's not even
a moot point and as Tom said this has
descended under silliness the the fact
is there is no breach of the decision we
made in June we have been told very
clearly there is a pathway where the
airport Bard is already addressing the
issue that has been raised this there is
no moot point in this discussion we have
a simple recommendation here about
respecting a long serving meor of our
community the other issue that has been
raised is one that is in
hand let's get on with it yep so um
Barry I'm quite quite prepared to Move
Motion excellent U so just as a
Reflection from my end um eelyn in the
previous discussion about whether we
table or not table in public
um a paper alluded to the fact that when
we had the previous decision we we left
the conditions of of dealing with these
issues because you rightly said we're
revisiting an issue again and I don't
want to keep revisiting this we name a
building so I guess what I'm signaling
to the to the staff or to Michael is
that that paper that was left on the
table needs to come back that was a
condition that we left it there that
they would come back with after
discussing with the two rakas where we
would go to from here and that needs to
come back otherwise we're going to have
this issue every time we want to discuss
something so Michael's writing that down
as we scho any further discussion
Peter yeah thank you uh Mr Mayor thanks
for making that very clear to our EVN
and I believe that mtim deserves this
he's not only done this for inago but
the province of Southland and has gone
Far and Beyond of any other M that we've
ever had so I would move that
recommendation um and so just as a
timing reflection um we're probably
looking about
mid-February um and as you might be
aware that we've got some other issues
that we need to resolve through that and
what what form that will take of the
ceremony that goes that goes with it so
that that's the time frame in case
people are asking you when are you're
going to actually do it
we're looking into that time frame
so R you took a deep breath to C's move
it twice yeah quite we're quite into
that so we've got to move on a second
any further discussion no there being
none all those in favor
carried excuse me oh sorry you want yep
absolutely you want to noted you're
opposed yeah I'm actually voting against
okay that's fine put on a PL at the aort
okay right next next agender item is the
parks and reserves land parcel review
update Caroline and K
welcome good afternoon councilor's May
Clark um so the paper you've got in
front of you there is uh it's an update
on continuation of a report that we
provided to the community well wellbeing
Committee in August um we're looking at
as um noting some of the progress we've
made on work that's done since August
and also just to confirm the approval of
um further land Parcels to work through
um and actually put forward into that
Park land disposal options and those uh
the following that process the updates
are on Aura and Moko those um papers
will come to the community wellbeing
Committee in the new year to give you
updates on those um and the master plan
progress on Donovan Farm is detailed
within the
paper the um decision today would
initiate the land disposal process for
the um for Point e uh three on the
recommendation so that's actually um
starting into the public consultation
process where the public will have the
opportunity to provide their submissions
with respect to the land Parcels being
proposed and submissions will then come
back to us following council
meeting just to look at what we've got
with the um a number of land Parcels is
we we manage all of our Green Space as a
reserve even it's not gazetted as such
so therefore each piece of Reserve Land
can have unique factors that will
require tailored different legal advice
and different ways of managing them um
so you know how we came to own the land
is found through subsequent processes
once we've started the process of land
disposal um we whilst we're aiming for a
singular approach to all of these land
Parcels it's not always possible
you have any questions yes indeed as you
would expect um so for my colleagues who
may not be aware I met with Caroline and
Rex and Michael yesterday about that and
I have some concerns about where we're
heading with this issue it's certainly
been a desire of council to move quickly
on these issues as we've discussed this
morning in our Workshop um the disposal
SL sale of these Parcels of land um
uh are a source of Revenue that we may
well need as we go forward in our
financial thinking in the next few
months and few years um and so um I
going to raise several issues now and I
want to get Darren's advice on one of
them but the other issue that we
discussed yesterday was do you need to
have a project or a reason for taking a
reserve status off so my desire was not
to worry about the ones that are not
Reserve status only the ones that are
reserved status uh the ones that are not
reserved and they just Council own land
we have an ability to to move them on so
it's the reserve status which is not
what's on our list in front of you
because some of those are called Reserve
but they are not actually reserves so
one I need clarification on that um
which ones are reserves secondly very
much would like a single approach so we
just bundle I think eight Parcels are
land together and go out to consultation
and get the feedback we get on all eight
do it in one hit um um and thirdly we
had some debate yesterday about what's
required under the reserves act to allow
us to change the status now I've read
that act a couple of times overnight so
going to sections 24 24a and 24 and 25
it is clear that we have to declare the
reason why we want the status removed
but it does not go further to say that
we need to have plans or designs or
anything else in place my interpretation
and I'm open to being convinced by
Michael or rex or yourself to the
contrary that that determination in the
act just says the reason for removing
the status is to either Freehold the
land or alternatively to dispose of it
which the ACT talks about and dispose
does not mean sell but having said that
a lay person would quite rightly say
there's only two ways of disposing of a
piece of land you either sell it or you
gift it to somebody now and I don't
think be much appetiz granty to be
gifting it but we may have some options
of of gifting some land if we wanted to
depending on where it is so need some
help on that legal clarification on 24
24a and 25 so thank you may we've um had
a good look into that today and I will
ask Chris who has been doing some
technical advice for me to give you an
answer there okay Chris K team uh thanks
M Clark and to to clarify your question
uh we're really trying to understand
what's required to start the land
disposal process so we do not need a a
proposal to start that land disposal
process we can go out to the community
and ask the community what they think
about this land parcel y so to start
that process off we go to our
commissioner uh to
determine whether that land was driv by
the crown and to get a formal opinion of
that land yep after we get that
information from the commissioner and
our Comm Community voice and our
council's wants and needs across
different parts of the city then we
provide advice to Council on what to do
with that parcel of land when we get to
the point of going back to the
commissioner for any revocation of land
they will want to know
why and so the information that they
will request will be different depending
on the parcel of land so if you want to
uh revocate a parcel of land that is of
high priority and strategically
important and we could say Queens Park
then the information that they'll want
to know will be much greater than a
reserve of lower importance and that is
not strategically significant so to
answer your question in a bit more black
and white no we do not need a specific
proposal to sell a parcel of land but
when we go back to the commissioner to
ask their uh to seek their permission uh
to revocate the land the amount of
information that they will want will
differ depending on the parcel of land I
hope that clarifies your question it
does um but just let me clarify so that
I'm clear on what you're saying so um I
understand the pathway to the
commissioner after the public
consultation that that public
consultation should be that we just wish
to dispose of the land our position is
it's no intrinsic value um to us as a
council that we have other needs so the
sale of the land could give us some
revenue or alternatively we may remove
the status and then use it ourselves in
a nonp Parks and Recreation setting so
we might put some Age Care units onto it
as an example so long as we're clear on
that I'm fine
um I'm going to come to Darren in a
minute about doing it in bulk because I
don't want this to be drawn out um and
so um we will need some clarification on
which ones we want to buy bundle
together because the list that you gave
us which is the colored list some time
ago differs from what's in the report
now and as Caroline said that may very
well be because we just call some
parcels of land reserves we in fact
they're not actually reserves um and so
that's that's the issue for us the other
issue for us is when we last discussed
this which was a couple of months ago
and you had the uh the drawings up on
the on the on the back wall as you as
you recall the process we would have
work through was um consult on a master
plan followed by Consulting on a
subsequent management plan then we would
go out to the community
on um a removal of the status if there
was status on the land followed followed
by an
approach um in the case of Donovan uh we
would need to approach the district plan
to change the boundaries to allow us to
do what we want to do um and I've said
before but I'll publicly say it again
for the record there is no legal
requirement for us under the ACT to have
a master plan it's something we do by
choice and that's okay I don't say it's
not good business but that can't hold up
our prices which is our wanting to
dispose of the land which you've put in
front of us so long as we're on the same
page with that we're in a good position
Darren if you'd like to talk to the
issue of um the issue of parceling up
those eight bundles of land and putting
them into public consultation as a group
as opposed to doing it
individually I I can't think of anything
under RMA process that sets a precedent
nor prevents it yeah um I think the
threshold for explanation of
declassification Y as Chris explained
varies from from parcel to parcel but
it's just it's going to make it a
weighty sure weighty document yep um
um and and and in there the explanations
for why you would be declassifying to
the
commissioner VY y
um if if you use Donovan park for
example traditionally part of it
was uh there is an intention to be able
to
show um Urban people what a working farm
was like such things are no longer a
novelty so whether they that form part
of it but to your question of parceling
up I'm not aware of any reason why you
couldn't the key question for me for you
was whe whether we do the bundling up of
the the eight Parcels or there might be
slightly more than that now um as a one
consultation to the community and people
can come in on the ones that they're
interested in uh that to me that doesn't
stop us then approaching the
commissioner individually on those
Parcels of land and giving specific
needs for would have those specific y um
items as as a part of your application y
you would need all
eight separately identified yep okay are
we on the same page Chris oh we are can
I provide a little bit more information
oh no sorry Darren ripped his hand up
laste I'm playing the devil's advocate
here because I can think of the fact
that we have a consultation process
underway just how that can be perceived
by the public if we come up with a
decision before it's
finished
um if I can ask Chris we we expected the
Donovan master plan to be finished uh
thank you uh early in the new year is
when we will expect the Donovan master
plan but the bit of information that I
wanted to clarify for you uh M Clark yep
um was around what we discussed back in
May around master plan management plan
and then going out again for a third
consultation yep uh there is the
potential that we can go out for that
consultation on revocation of land
during the management plan process sure
if we wanted to Fast Track so I was just
clarifying yeah I understand that but I
guess when we had discussion this is not
me trapping you in anyway when we had
the same discussion about Sandy Point
master plan as well it seemed to be
certainly from my perspective and it
might just be my perspective these
Master plans can be 10e plans or they
can be 50 year plans depending on how
they're interpreted and we seem to have
issues that still fell between the two
sets of plans management and master plan
U Cooper Creek good example and so I
just um had some unease about the use of
Master plans in that way I guess whether
we have them as a um I don't know an
overarching for our key strategy
certainly you'd want one for Queens Park
and you'd certainly want one for Sandy
Point but the other places would you a
master plan for I don't know tvi Street
or whatever
um you're done Darren I think so you
think so
excellent so before I go on some of my
colleagues that want to have a few words
on this so long as we can be clear
shortly about um which ones have Reserve
status as opposed to being called
reserved that would be really helpful
doesn't need to be near so that's um we
can go up public consultation following
that public but to go out for public
consultation what we will want to do is
go to the statutary land manager to
ensure that we are aware absolutely on
each par of land just before we do that
so I have another personal question for
you it's and I said this to you
yesterday but tongue and cheek some ways
is it a bit ethically hard for a parks
and Reserve management team to be
selling off some parks and reserves
following the guidance or elected
members yeah I know and is this no I'm
just I'm just trying to be practical is
this something that should be activated
somewhere else in the
organization without looking at Michael
day to consider that but I mean is there
somebody else that we should be tapping
on a shoulder given that you have a lot
of workload as well and I don't I would
say m CL because of our understanding
and expertise around the reserves act it
sits best with us okay that's fine you
know that's all cool I'd agree right
here we go to Grant yeah just a point to
clarification so if we say and go
through the process of and calling it
disposal of land does that restrict or
prevent us from retaining that so say
for example we got a piece of land
that's reserved land we go through this
consultation process but then we say we
don't want to sell that because it's
become strategic does that implicate the
consultation process do we have to say
we we may dispose of it we may retain it
we I'm just trying to
understand maybe I can help with that
Grant
before you get in there Caroline um the
removal of the status does not mean that
we're disposing of the land it's just
removing the status so if we removed a
statement of saake on Sor Park yeah we
might not want to dispose of it or sell
it or gift it or anything else we might
just want to retain it without it stated
so we could build on it ourselves if we
wanted to so so therefore is the wording
and the sort of it's not clear does it
need to be change of status just I'm
just trying to make sure we sort of are
clear with the public around what trying
to achieve but equally we don't get
bound into saying oh you said you're
going to dispose it in a consultation
process and then we retain it for
whatever reason in the future so yeah
just trying to understand we need to be
clear in our consultation documents when
we go out to the public exactly what
we're asking them yeah so at a PR but we
can have a couple of sorry sorry at a
previous meeting we made a decision that
we would not put up for disposal s Park
or tvia Street
yeah so they were off the agenda Yeah
well yeah
I'm thinking in particular like to the
bluff camping ground y you know
strategically I believe that could be a
very good asset for that Community I've
got interest in that people are
interested in developing that yeah so
well it's on the list there's potential
disposal we we may not be intending to
do
that so just might decide they don't
want to do around that par of land in
particular there is a a long-term lease
on there as a camping ground so for us
to dispose of the land as a a council
land does not mean it would not no
longer be a camping ground cuz the lease
would continue with the
land we owned it the leas will continue
yeah but so yeah do you know is that CL
for's Reserve now it is it's part of our
go park reserve okay so as part of this
process to release it thank
you no
no pushing glasses up with you I was I
just moving my hands lizy thank you mine
is also a um clarification Point there's
been mention made of eight Parcels of
land but the document I'm looking at has
actually got 14 Parcels of L and two
tranches of five and nine yes so can we
just be clear on which eight Parcels we
are talking about correct and that's
what I was suggesting before that the
the original document that colored one
had Reserve or non-reserve
classification on
when we get to this document it's got
some names called Reserve but they're
not actually reserves Under The Reserve
Act that's the difficulty we have so can
can can we delineate which eight Parcels
we're talking about here and now or does
this need to go away and come
back seems seems to me if we're going
talk any further we need everybody needs
to be clear about which eight Parcels
have become the point of the discussion
and what's the purpose of those
well let let me work through it for you
they might might clarify so Moco MCO is
on the list as a reserve but it's not
actually a reserve in accordance with
the original disposal list that we
got Donovan Park Farm it just says part
but that actually is Reserve landal Land
and Bluff Hill Reserve again is not a
reserve according to the original list
but they it's called a reserve
so this is the complication that we have
as we go through and then the bottom
list it gets even more complicated and
our r b sorry
um well I'll just go through the
listening you'll know Rockdale um isn't
declared as a reserve but it is actually
a res this is based on the original list
Conway Cresent playground is a reserve
Newfield Park is a reserve Elizabeth
Street Reserve is not a reserve uh
Vernon Street res Reserve part is not a
reserve um McMillan Street is a reserve
so that's okay Bluff camping ground is
Reserve Land P that and the next two
which is JG Ward and 38 SE Street are
listed as reserves but they're not
reserves M uh through S M Clark um the
the parcel of eight was actually
mentioned by the chair not by um the
report all the staff the staff have nine
Parcels of land included in the uh
recommendation three um all need to go
through the process as as highlighted by
the staff the process we need to
actually check uh what the legal the
formal legal status is because sometimes
we've gone through doesn't have a status
on it and then we' found out when we've
gone through that legal process there
ISS Associated to the land so we've got
to follow that process for all nine so
all nine will go through that process so
there there are nine Parcels are land in
that um the ones in um recommendation
two already have a process in place and
you were getting an update in relation
to those so a number of those are
already through a process and they will
need to come back in relation to where
they're up to uh for the next stage and
you've had the indication of the
timeline for that being in early in the
New Year in relation to those properties
so for your just to answer your question
Leslie I'm hoping that early in the New
Year key word being early um we get a
list back from Parks and Recreation that
tells us which ones are reserves and
which ones aren't and our our initial um
workload is to remove the reserve status
the ones that don't have Reserve stat I
guess we can sell it anytime um it's
just and we make choices about that
which ones we want to dispose of which
ones we don't but getting those Reserve
status out of the way seems to be the
way so that's for all 14 you're talking
about because I think that as Michael
quite rightly says while while work is
underway given the original list and the
current one that's in front of us one
two three of the four and two are
actually incorrect well there's
conflicts about the status Y and we need
that clarified as well then we'll know
which ones we need to bundle together
that's what we do and go out to public
consultation Chris I'll come back to you
here I just want to add a little bit of
information to help help you understand
our process so when we decide that we're
going to go through a land disposal
process the first step is that we have a
conversation with the commissioner and
at that point they will confirm what the
land status is so it's not necessarily
parks and wck going away and coming back
to you uh there is um different whether
your land Information Services or land
information New Zealand or the
commissioner the commissioner is the
regulatory Authority that will inform us
of what the land status is okay it'll be
dependent on the turnaround time that
comes back from the commissioner we will
come back to as soon as we can so how do
you decide which ones of the 14 that are
on this current paper are you going to
go and talk to the commissioner about if
we want to just remove the status
because at this stage we're not saying
to the commission we want to dispose of
the land we just want to remove the
status uh so as as part of
recommendation three uh we're noting
feedback as first s through the bluff
community board but we can so that's um
with respect to items g h and I uh and
so after we've gone to the bluff
community board then we can go straight
to the Department of Conservation to
confirm the status of all those Parcels
of land so that's all
14 no that's all that's all
nine so so what happens to the what
happens to the three of the four on the
top area and two that have conflicting
advice from
Parks
sorry could you repeat the question
please well and and and sorry the five
that are setting up under under
recommendation two are M MCO Donovan W
sportsfield and part of bluff Hill the
original Vice we got on the paper this
this one here does not tie up for four
of those
properties so two are a corner Reserve
that's B and E are called reserves well
in fact they're not reserves and Donovan
is not called Reserve an effect there is
a reserve I understand so the original
paper that you're alluding to was that
was the indication we had as we say we
need to go back to the commissioner to
confirm so that's what we've been doing
okay so the there is the original paper
that you're referring back to with the
reserves names that's where we've gone
that's the indication that we have y but
as we say we we do name all of the green
spaces we look after a reserve so it's a
it's a naming convention that we all use
yeah but I guess from app or we then go
back to the commissioner to from our
perspective we don't want to be
backwards and forwards with the
commissioner so my recommendation is you
take all 14 parel of land that are on
those two lists you go to the commission
and say we just want to clarify the
status here once we have the status and
if so far say eight or nine of them are
Reserve status then we start the process
to remove their status absolutely we
have already done that for the first
five so we are awaiting a commissioner
response for the first five okay so
that's why we're not bundling all 14
together because we wouldn't want to
double up with the commissioner sure
okay I'm sorry Chris actually um touched
on what I was going to say about the
passes land I'm going to ask a really
stupid question because I've asked a
couple people that don't know the answer
to it um under um item two uh E when
you've got the part of bluff ho
reserve the question I was asking is do
you know which part it is
yes build so well obviously there's a
part so which part is it it's the it's a
subdivided part um around Flagstaff road
okay
yeah so the other issue I have is that
um Michael said Michael Day said to me
yesterday that when we did the original
paper which is this
one um we didn't confirm which ones we
wanted to dispose of we just just
accepted your list but didn't say we
want to give the green light to it so I
guess one of the things we need to do
today is confirm that we want them all
dispos of with the exception of s Park
and tvia Street which are in the red so
do you need a motion to that
effect that's
do that's recommendation
three okay except that recommend three
currently applies to only the nine
yes
yep so as L quite rightly said we need
to change the recommendation two to
include the similar sort of wording on
recommendation three which confirms that
we want to dispose of those Parcels of
land because two doesn't say that and
our beloved Donovan p is in that
cluster through yourself Mia you're
currently in a consultation process in
relation to some of the ones in option
two so couldn't go down that front just
at the moment be in conflict with your
consultation you can do that um they're
the ones to come back in the new year um
in relation to the feedb consultation
with whom the commission the
public commissioner I'll just say
quietly
bugger the option two is it not
currently the commissioner yeah asking
for
his sorry can I just SE clarification so
under the option
two are they not currently did you not
my may have misunderstood you but are
you in consultation now with the
commissioner so to identify so um if I
bring us back to the paper that came to
the Community wellbe Committee in August
yeah um the recommendation to on that
paper was for us to that the following
land parel have begun the disposal
process so we actually did start that
one um with that's AA and M Moko those
are the two Parcels that are in there
already right so we've already started
on those
ones I would only add to that that
they're different stages through the
process so some are with the
commissioner some are yet to be with the
commission so they're different St it
comes back from the commissioner then we
seek consultation with or in the point
on point two some of those we've already
started that process because it was
started in
August okay do not suit so help help me
clarify again so while Michael Day gives
me the advice that we haven't determined
that we want to dispose of the land
surely if you're going through a process
that says from the land disposal options
you've already
activated part or all of those five
surely that's an indication to
management that we want to dispose the
land because why else would you be going
down that track yeah I'll come to you
re
yep uh through you be clar I just wanted
to try and get some
clarification or some yeah certainly
some clarity around there's a couple of
confusing points here and the language
that we're using one is we're using the
language around disposal
uh a disposal process and when we're
talking about reserves we actually are
talking about the
revocation and so they're quite
different um and if we're going to the
commissioner with respect to
um the status and checking the status
we're checking the status of the land to
see whether we can revoke it's Reserve
status not to dispose of it that's
correct and that's so so going back to
recommendation two and what the staff
have talked about is that there is a
couple of those reserves and this is me
coming and obviously late to the piece
two days in um but that's plenty enough
but it's with fresh eyes and fresh ears
that I'm now trying to get an
explanation for myself here that this is
helping me to understand that um what
we're asking with regards to reserves or
or land Parcels that are of a reserve
status is about the the revoking of that
Reserve status primarily and I would say
as general as to go into a freehold
status so that then we can decide what
you want to do after that correct um so
and and we again we the conf well not
confusion but further the clarification
lies is there are some of
those um Parcels of land that are
identified that aren't Reserve
status uh in in recommendation
three um and I think we should just
focus the convers focus the resolution
that we ask you to consider on the
parcels of land that are of Reserve
status to initiate the revocation
process with the commissioner yeah
correct so that's that's where I've been
trying to get to um but I I guess one of
the things that's sullied the water a
little bit for me is that we've done
some consultation on a master plan SL
management plan for Donovan and in doing
so that creates some Community
expectations about what would we use it
for going forward where in fact actually
we don't want to use it going forward
even though that might be a debate we
actually want to dispose of the
farm although m it was one of the
options that was being discussed in the
consultation because when I was at one
of the stands it was something that
people were were asking us about so it's
obviously out there um you don't want to
predetermine either your worship um
going forward when it comes to any of
the discussions that we've got in front
of us y I wondered if excuse me on
recommendation number three it could be
as simple as adding the word revocation
and when we consult with the or public
not publicly notify with the community
through a land disposal or Reserve
revocation process pursuant to the
reserves act could literally just be as
simple as that because then that leaves
it open-ended for us to either dispose
of those that aren't listed currently as
a reserve or revoke the status on those
that aren't
uh yep and and from my end I guess I
just want to make sure that if we are
Consulting with the community that we're
not Consulting in a way that doesn't
declare that we may wish to dispose of
we' got to be upfront about that
otherwise we leave as El open to whole
lots of moral and ethical issues that we
had a predetermined position to sell the
land because we've had this report for
six months and we just gone through the
motions Leslie thank you um M Clark I I
could I suggest that we take a 10minute
recess to reord two and three y to add
in the necessary reference to revocation
yeah and to adjust where some of the
Parcels of land are currently sitting I
think probably a 10-minute recess would
help to come back with so something that
so the latter part of that what were you
looking for sorry in the latter part of
that you you see the revocation B which
I understand but you were also
clarifying what
else that uh the various Parcels of land
that are sitting in two and three y
might need some adjustment about which
area they are sitting
in
might help to sort that out yep I can do
that okay we have a 10minute recess we
do toilets drinks and
uhu Rex you get to do your first
amendment I I don't actually know if
that's
okay we back live streaming
folks okay so you'll see some rewarding
up the board Michael's going to explain
why he's taken W by Sports field and
part of bluff Hill Reserve which is what
we had clarification number four down to
three as opposed to being a two
thank you may clerk um just working
through the decisions that were made by
uh the community and wellbeing committee
and then via Council in
August the community and well-being um
committee put forward to council that um
the AR and Moko were to be go through
the land disposal process so those are
just merely updates uh from that Pro um
purpose the decision around Donovan farm
at that time was to go through the
consultation process so we will need to
bring back a paper in February which we
indicated before in relation to the
disposal uh process should that be the
outcome in relation to Donovan Farm um
but note the amendments to why Hopey
Sports field and to the part Bluff Hill
Reserve those two had not been approved
in the August to go down they were they
were on our original paper that was
items 4 to six that didn't get approved
um but the actual minutes had them
sitting in a different category so we've
put those down to go through the land
disposal process so that means all will
be in the land disposal and rication
process um except for Donovan Farm which
is currently in consultation process to
go to um come back in February okay just
need to clarify one thing Michael on M M
my
uh original list said it's not a reserve
is that changed no that's correct it's
not a
reserve
just it's protected under the reserves
act but it's not derived by the
crown no I'm not sure I got the answer I
wanted there so is it is it a Reserve
Act where we need to move the Reserve I
know about the crown
stuff we have a paper on both AO and M
Moka coming back to Council in the early
New Year year yeah on all of the process
and the consultation that we've
undertaken on those two land Parcels
which will have all of that information
clearly documented back for the council
at that time okay thank
you Grant's looking at me I can read his
mind he's saying don't lose sight of
Donovan and why is that and why is that
predetermined why is that because there
is huge amount predeter outcome with
that piece of passive left yeah
well just you can explain the right P
what we 15% as opposed to eight never
mind just wonder for clarity should we
put the piece of land that we're going
to talk to the bluff Community about in
terms of which is i j and k only isn't
it so just put them in
Brackets that's in the next steps it's
outlined in the
paper y but in the motion it's not clear
as
it
since now yeah that's right and K should
be
here g g h and I oh sorry g g
i
leave may want
to possibly K yes K might be a good idea
yeah could be so it's g h i all clear on
it
yep Leslie's already nodded so that
means she's putting the motion down
thank you um any further discussion on
those all those in favor I Carri well
done thank you
Caroline thank you
may right where are we at
now okay so number 19 is a response to
the omon report in regards to open
business
who's speaking to that you are yes
excellent just before we lead into that
just a a quick Reflection from my end
it's pleasing that we are well ahead of
the eightball on what the OM has
required we've been live streaming for
quite some time and I've had significant
inquiries from other councils about how
we actually do that um for me there are
there are a couple of issues one is the
a recording of questions asked at
meetings and I'm not sure we are quite
detailed enough on that
whether we just say there was a general
discussion about ab and C or whether we
need to be a bit more specific when they
asked specific questions so that's
something you can give us some guidance
on Michael um and the other issues the
issue that rangy quite rightly raised
which I'm going to raise this Friday
about when we attend other meetings that
we are stakeholder to whether this sort
of criteria should also apply to them as
well ringy just a a point there the Wast
net meeting is uh fully agenda in our
agendas and also live stream okay and
that's the three Council y excellent y
Michael floor is yours car thank you M
Clark um so and you are quite correct
the ombudsman's report raised quite a
number of interesting uh issues as he uh
surveyed um five uh councils but this
also Builds on the work that he had
already undertaken uh here when he had
completed his own investigation of our
practices relating to ler uh in 2020 so
it was a building on
of that for us um and M Clark is quite
correct we are already ahead of a number
of councils in terms of live streaming
and in terms of our workshops uh what
this paper focuses on primarily is the
issue of the workshop because the umman
has quite an wide uh definition of what
capture is captured in a workshop so the
essential issue is anytime that staff
provide advice to counselors uh that
triggers the workshop requirements under
the ombudsman's uh guidance so Council
are only sessions where um the chief
executive is present is excluded from
that but a councelor only session that
would have other staff so any GMS or uh
managers presenting information is
information sharing it is captured by
the workshop requirements and you need
to go through the process of determining
whether it should be in public which is
the default setting uh or whether you
should be in public excluded uh so to
move workshops into public excluded
you'll need to undertake the uh process
you took this morning um which is to
have the formal resolution um read out
to move it into public excluded so that
it sets that tone for the public that
you have
considered whether this should be in
public excluded or not uh you will have
the advantage of Staff advice around
that because we will have um a process
in place uh for them for staff who are
requesting a workshop to provide us with
that information as to whether the staff
consider it should be in public excluded
or not uh and of course as the decision
makers the ultimate decision as to
whether it goes into public or not is
for you to
determine um so that's that is sort of
the key focus of what this paper for me
was focusing on as to uh bring you up to
speed with what we will be doing on that
so you will see uh workshops appear and
their advertisements in the Southland
times because I'm sure you look for
those at the start of um at the end of
each month um like I do um you're a
sicker and also on our website got get a
more of a life you
really um so you'll you'll see that uh
the point councelor pottinger has raised
around our joint committees is something
that I will be raising with um my
colleagues in South Lin and Gore um our
approach will be that our joint
committees will be open to the public
where possible uh but that's something
that we need to do in conjunction with
our our colleagues and our partner
councils it's not something that we can
uh decree I think at the start of wa the
waset meeting at this term there was an
agreement that they would be live
streamed where possible uh so that is a
good indication of the way uh
forward uh I said the Ombudsman was uh
quite encompassing when he looked
through Loma practices the minutes is
something that we have been uh working
on I think the ombudsman's test was
would someone in 20 years be able to
understand how count who made that
decision prob not listen to us that's
you
down um and so he was looking at
essentially what is he was calling an
audit Trail uh so that people could
understand how uh
that how Council arrived at that
decision it's an interesting contrast to
the advice coming through from lgz which
was to resolution Focus um minutes so
it's trying to find that happy ground it
is something that we and my team have
been working on uh this term uh we had
quite strong guidance from the council
that you wanted more information in your
minutes but not to go to such an extent
of the beta minutes because that's in no
one's interest um so we're still finding
that balance I think we're better than
where we were um but we will continue to
take um guidance from Council around
that and of course the opportunity at
each time you receive your minutes is to
um ask for some of that information to
be put in if you consider uh a general
discussion was held uh to be inadequate
for those purposes uh one of the other
things to note is that the Ombudsman has
indicated that we should record um all
votes where it was not unanimous uh
regardless of whether the person asked
for their vote to be recorded an
opposition or not and that includes any
extensions uh so that is something that
we will uh start capturing uh going
forward um I'm pleased to say most of
your decisions are unanimous so that is
um very pleasing uh so with that I'm
very happy to take any
questions
Tom um when you talked about uh joint
committees of course Great South is a
joint shareholders committee as opposed
to a joint committee of council so I
wondered whether it did apply though
which we've sort of assumed during this
meeting the second question was there
are I can think of one at least there
probably more than that you know joint
working part if you think of the climate
change working party which is not a
joint committee um it's an informal
joint committee if you small G small c
um I mean would that be captured in
terms of requirement to be public yeah
so our understanding around that and it
includes uh councelor der's Ro as a
project lead for uh the project 1225 um
because again he's receiving staff
advice the answer to that is from what
we understand in the orman's report is
no because they are it's a working group
on a specific task that is then
reporting back to council it's not a
committee of this Council uh that is
receiving that information it's a it's
potentially a Fone line it may be
something that the Ombudsman may come
back and provide further guidance on but
at this stage we're comfortable that
those sort of working groups are not
captured by these requirements for a
workshop and the first part of that
which was about the joint shareholders
Committee of Great South which is not
Joint Committee of council because
there's other shareholders involved in
it but we talked as though that would be
captured by where that kind of feels
yeah so so it's been it's been always
considered and treated as a joint
committee uh that is something that we
will need to work through with all of
our shareholders around that as to what
level of capture that comes within the
Ombudsman um discussion around that uh
the starting point from council's I
suspect would be that it is considered
and treated as a joint committee of the
councils uh that has partner
shareholders
involved uh that that the starting point
would be that it should be open uh but I
wouldn't want to predetermine that
discussion with our colleague councils
or indeed our um the other joint
shareholders okay thank you I'll raise
up on Friday at the meeting yeah at the
Minal meeting start the discussion off
about the
oh sorry R um look when I started on
here in 2 10 our minutes were
unbelievable in verbatim yeah and when
we got our agenda pack for that Tuesday
or whatever it was that thick and half
the thickness was the verbatim minutes
that were taken now obviously we changed
to where we are now but you know it
seems as seems quite weird that we would
have done that back then and then
obviously dropped the practice to just
the simple resolution so we went from
one extreme to the complete
other so we're trying to get back to
somewhere in between sure
every um it's just a point of
clarification we
record everything that is live
streamed do we still record what we
don't live
stream the in committee part of your
meeting we make no recordings of that
the official record of our meeting is
the minutes the minutes so in as much
as eventually most of what we do in
committee comes back to a public
meeting most of what our deliberations
would be are captured on the live stream
how long do we keep that and is that not
our
um sort of clarification of discussion
for want of a better word because I'm
really mindful that I really don't like
he said she said minutes and that
capturing the essence is really what
we're doing that the recordings are the
backup so what we're missing is what we
have in PX is that is that correct we we
only have minutes for that so the under
both the Local Government Act and goer
uh the official record of a council
meeting is the minutes once they have
been confirmed by Council or the
committee uh the live stream is a record
but it is not the official record of
what happened was at at the meeting uh
so when it comes to public excluded
because we don't have a recording of it
um there is no other option for anybody
else to go and view that it's simply the
record is captured in the
minutes uh until either of the actors
acts are changed um and refocus what is
the official record of a meeting um that
is the only practice we can have no
thank you for that clarification because
I would have thought technology was our
friend in this in this circumstance I
would say just remember ler as a 1987
act
true we you said you know Peter yeah I'm
sure in the early days of my life on
Council here all meetings were recorded
and that at times when there was any
anyone not sure of what was said they
went back there for a clarification do
you remember that Darren yes there was
an audio record was definitely until the
minutes have been transcribed was on a
vile T
yeah oh that's really so why did why
were that previous yeah council do away
with that CU it was valuable information
and it did Pro very valuable at times Y
and there was a we maintained it Peter
right up until we started streaming
yep okay so uh we've got a paper or
respon in front of us some like to move
that we receive that Grant Andria thank
you any further discussion all those in
favor I carried so now I'm going to go
into PE even though we have paper you're
interested in Alex sitting there because
I want to get through the paper on the
name of Tisbury while p is still here
who's going to go in about 10 minutes so
I don't want to lose her input into that
so um if somebody would like to move we
go into
PE you get those two yep that dropping
down I think was a this is the final
straw um all those in favor carried
welcome again
right
and